[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه
رغم وعود التسليح جناح اوروبي يدعو للحوار
مع موسكو واكياب تصر على انها اوقعت روسيا
في فخباخمت
يرفض التراجع حتى ينهم وصفه بانقلاب الجيش
وتحذير اممي من اتساع نطاق الحرب
يبعثر اوراق جوله الاعاده التركيه بتاييد
اردوغان وتحالفه يعيد ترتيبها ويؤكد ان
قرره شخصي
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تمديدا للصدام بعرابه ترامب ديسانتس يرسم
طريقه للبيت الابيض عبر جائزه ايوا
والصفقات مع الجمهوريين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من الملف الاوكراني
وتباينات واضحه في المواقف الاوروبيه خلال
الساعات الاخيره المستشار الالماني او
لاشولز وصفات تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على مقاتلات 16 بانها اشاره الى الرئيس
الروسي للتراجع عن اهدافه مضيفا في
تصريحات لصحيفه فيلتل المانيا ان بوتين لن
يحقق هدفه من خلال الحرب واوضح شولص ان
المانيا لا تملك طائرات اف 16 لتزويد
اوكرانيا بها الا انها تقوم بالتزويد كياف
بالدفاعات الجويه والعربات المدرعه
والمدفعيه الثقيله على حد قوله
في مقابل موقف شولز قال وزير خارجيه
النمسا الكسندر شانبرغ انه لا ينبغي ان
تسبق اوكرانيا دول اخرى اوروبيه للانضمام
للاتحاد مشيرا لذلك الى دول البلقان واضاف
ان انضمام اوكرانيا يجب ان لا يكون اولويه
بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي واوضحا ان بلاده
تحتفظ بقنوات اتصال غير السميه مع موسكو
وان على الغرب مواصله الحوار مع روسيا
كونها اكبر قوه نوويه على الارض كما اعتبر
ان هناك فرصه للحوار مع موسكو عبر منظمه
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا والامم المتحده
وان هناك مسؤوليه عالميه تقع على عاتق دول
الغربيه في هذا المجال
في الاثناء اعلن وزير خارجيه الدنمارك عن
رغبه بلاده في استضافه قمه تجمع روسيا
واوكرانيا للتوصل الى حل سلمى كما اكد
الوزير ان القمه ستستدعي حضور كل من الهند
والصين والبرازيل وليس فقط الدول الحليفه
لاوكرانيا مطالبا بالتزام عالمي لتنظيم
القمه
يشير حلف الناتو دائما الى انه لا يريد
التورط في الحرب باوكرانيا غير ان واشنطن
لا تمانع باستهداف شبه جزيره القرم
بمقاتلات اف 16 التي ستمنح اوكرانيا
باعتبارها اراضي اوكرانيه الامر الذي يمكن
ان يحول امريكا والناتو الى مشاركين
مباشرين في هذه الحرب
بمناسبه او بدونها الغرب وحلف شمال
الاطلسي يؤكدان مرارا وتكرارا انهما لا
يودان التورط في الحرب باوكرانيا غير ان
المؤشرات قد تقود لعكس ذلك تماما نقطه
التحول في المعادله طائره اف 16 وشبه
جزيره القرم
مقاتله ستكون في يدكيف قريبا هي مساعده
عسكريه غربيه للجيش الاوكراني من اجل
الدفاع عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه كل الاراضي
وفق واشنطن البيت الابيض اعلن انه لا
يمانع استهداف شبه الجزيره التي سيطرت
عليها روسيا العام 2014 منطقه تعتبرها
موسكو جزءا من اراضيها هنا تكمن كلمه السر
او نقطه التحول في المواجهه بين الغرب
وروسيا القرم قد تصبح نقطه رماديه خطيره
ستجعل الولايات المتحده والناتو مشاركين
مباشره في الحرب
ستدعم مبادره مشتركه لحلفائها لتدريب
طيارين اوكرانيين على طائرات اف 16 خلال
مده التدريب الذي سيستمر لاشهر سيقرر
الغرب موعد تسليم الطائرات وعددها وكذلك
الدول التي ستوفرها روسيا شددت على ان
ارسال هذه المقاتلات الى اوكرانيا سيثير
تساؤلات عن ضلوع حلف شمال الاطلس في
الصراع واي هجوم اوكراني على شبه جزيره
القرم سيعد هجوما على روسيا تقول موسكو
مقاتله اف 16 والهجوم على شبه جزيره القرم
قد يجران الولايه المتحده وحلف الناتو الى
معترك المواجهه المباشره واشنطن لا ترغب
في التورط وقد تتبرا من اي هجوم محتمل لكن
فوق اجواء القرم رياح مضطربه وخطيره بلال
الوجداني العربيه
اسم مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه الخاصه
بسب ب وجود
معتبرا ان العمليه العسكريه الخاصه تحولت
الى حرب شامله
في الواقع هناك حرب مستمر اليوم تحولت
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الى حرب شامله
ليست هذه المره الاولى في مناطق بيلكرود
وكورسكو وبريانسك التي نشهد فيها انفجارات
وقتل اشخاص
وفي التطورات الميدانيه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تدميرا مستودعات اسلحه
وذخيره ومعدات طائرات اوكرانيه في مطار
دنيبرو باستخدام اسلحه عاليه الدقه وقلل
المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه ايغور ان
الضربه كانت دقيقه ونجحت في تحقيق الهدف
منها
قالت الدفاع البريطانيه ان روسيا بدات
تشكيل قوات نخبه جويه هجوميه لدعم المعارك
على الارض في اوكرانيا وافادت في احدث
تقييم استخباراتي بان هذه القوات تدعى
ومدعومه بمقاتلات سوخوي 24 وصوخوي 34
ومروحيات هجوميه قتاليه واشارت الدفاع
البريطانيه الى ان روسيا تستقطب طيارين
عسكريين ذوي خبرات كبيره لضمهم لفرقه
النخبه الجديده
ضاره نافعه هذا هو حال الجيش الاوكراني
بعد اعلان قوات فاجنر السيطره على مدينه
قالت في تقرير لها ان محاوله روسيا
الاحتفاظ بالمدينه ربما ستدفعها لارسال
تعزيزات في محاوله لتثبيت سيطرتها على
وبالفعل اشار تقرير استخباراتي بريطانيا
يوم السبت الى ان موسكو اعادت انتشار عده
كتائب لتعزيز قواتها في بخموت اوكرانيا
بحسب نيوركتاينز ستلجا للاستيلاء على
المرتفعات حول باخوه هذه المرتفعات التي
نراها وهو ما اكدته فعليا النائبه وزير
الدفاع هنا ماليور عندما قالت ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استعادت مرتفعات شمال وجنوب
المدينه ما سيعقد وجود الروس في باق موت
اوكرانيا ستواصل ايضا تطويق المدينه من
عده جهات في محاوله لاستنزاف القوات
الروسيه داخل باخموت وتحويلها
احرق لهذه القوات ولم تكتفي اوكرانيا بذلك
بل واصلت جلب تعزيزات لدعم المواقع
الخلفيه وايضا تامين طرق الامداد غرب اخد
في الجانب الروسي تواجه القوات تحديات عده
فقائد مجموعه فاجنر اعلنت تسليم المدينه
للجيش الروسي يوم الخميس لكن الانسحاب على
طول خط المواجهه لن يتم دون عواقب حتى على
الروس في المدينه وفق نيويورك تايمز كما
ان استنفاذ عده وحدات روسيه لقواها سيضع
روسيا في موقف دفاعي عبر كل خط المواجهه
تقريبا والذي يمتد لمئات الكيلومترات
بعدما ركزت موسكو على السيطره على بخموت
بطبيعه الحال وهنا يبدو ان استنزاف القوات
الروسيه على اختلاف مسمياتها سيضعف قدرتها
على صد الهجوم المضاد الذي تخطط له
اوكرانيا في شرق البلاد وفق خبراء عسكريين
وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسكو
سيرجي شاشكاف المحلل العسكري اهلا بك معنا
الليله سيد سيرجي يعني ما حقيقه السيطره
على باخموت لانه اوكرانيا تصر بانها اوقعت
الروس في المصيده في الفخ هم داخل الفخموت
هي موجوده على المرتفعات
تطوقهم من كل الجهات وهي تمتلك قرار اطلاق
النار ماذا ان كانت هذه خطه اوكرانيه
مساء الخير بالفعل هناك تصريحات عديده
وارده بنكيف بان مدينه ضخمه او ار توماسك
هي صارت توماس كبير تاريخ 20 ايار روسيه
يعني رجعت الى امها وامتها
فتقول كيف ان المدينه هذه محاصره والجيش
الاوكراني يستعيد لاعاده السيطره عليها
والهجوم قريب والى اخره كل هذه
دعايه
ولا اكثر من ذلك
فيما يخص جماعه اتفاقنا برفاعي سوف تنسحب
وحدات من ضخمه في تاريخ 25 يعني بعد يومين
وتحد محلها الوحدات من الجيش الروسي
النظامي
راينا الى اهميه مدينه بحد ذاتها اكرر ان
من الناحيه العسكريه ليست لها قيمه اطلاقا
لان
وراها خد دفاعي قوي ومحسن من مدينه
اقوى
عمليا
من الناحيه العسكريه
صحيح ولكن
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول بان قواتنا
ما زالت تتقدم على جانبي باخموت وهذا ما
تؤكده ايضا نائبه وزير الدفاع بانه القوات
الاوكرانيه تشن حملات عسكريه
وعمليات على الاطراف
يعني وكانه القوات الروسيه هي داخل
باخ موت والقوات الاوكرانيه على الاطراف
وهو ما يعزز الفرضيه التي ذكرناها بالعرض
الماضي بانه يمكن للقوات الاوكرانيه ان
تطوق القوات الروسيه
كل التصريحات هذه
راميه الى تصفيه التاثير السلبي الكبير
نتيجه لان في
ضربه اعلاميه وسياسيه كبيره جدا ليس على
كيف فحص ولكن الغرب ايضا لان
تكرار ومرارا ان هذا الرسم رمز الصمود
والتصدي ولا يمكن ان يستولي الجيش الروسي
او جماعه
باي حال من الاحوال الان الجيش الروسي
موجود في داخل داخل
بخموت
واجمل الجيش الاوكراني على الفرار وكان
هناك
الويه يعني ليست
كبساريه او كتيبه كانت هناك كانوا عديده
والان هي مطروده بالكامل من بخبوت فلذلك
لحفاظ على
السمعه
لاغراض الدعايه نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني تقول هذا وهو وزير الدفاع كل
هذا
تبقى في قلوب ما خطه روسيا للتصدي للاف
سته عشر عندما
تتسلمها اوكرانيا كيف ستتعامل موسكو مع
ذلك
لا شك في ان القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه سوف
تستلم الطائرات اف 16 لا يشك في ذلك
نهائيا
فتبعا القياده العسكريه الروسيه والاداره
السياسيه تحسب هذا الحساب في خطاتها
العسكريه بغيت تقويه منظومات الدفاع الجوي
وبغيت ومعالجه هذا هذا الخطر الجديد
باستخدام اساليب جديده
ناهيكم عن ان التدريب التايرين
الاوكرانيين على هذا النوع الجديد من
السلاح الجوي في 16
يستغرق فكره لا اقل من اربعه اشهر حتى ولو
ابتدا تدريب الكادر الجوي الاوكراني في
بعض الدول الاوروبيه
فليس هناك اي خطر استراتيجي ولكن استلام
3/6 حتما سوف يشكل بعد متاعب وعرقل
لسير العمليات
المحلل العسكري الروسي
شكرا لكم
انتصار بنكهه الحذر اعلنت هوموسكو في
باخمت وان كان الاعتماد فيه على قوات
فاغنر للسيطره على تلك المدينه فقط فلا بد
لها من اعاده ترتيب صفوف القوات الروسيه
الرسميه باختصار القوات الروسيه تتغير
على مدى اشهر استنزفت روسيا قوات النخبه
التي عرفت
على خطوط القتال الاماميه تستعد عنها
اليوم بقوات شتورن وفق ما بينته وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه مجموعه طيران من طراز
النخبه قد تشهد مبارزه قاسيه مع مقاتلات
اف 16 في سماء اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وحده مدعمه بمقاتلات 24 واربعه وثلاثين
تتولى المناوره الجويه
وطائراتها تتولى مهام الهجوم الارضي
تقدم حققته القوات الروسيه متوغله في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه طوال فتره الحرب
وقبلها في شبه جزيره القرم مكتسبات
ستحميها موسكو بكل السبل متركزه في نقاط
اساسيه معظمها جنوب اوكرانيا بحسب
خنادق وحواجز وتحصينات رصدتها البي بي سي
من خلال صور الاقمار الصناعيه لتحدد تمركز
نقاط الدفاع والتكتكه الدفاعيه
جنوب اقليم زابوريا حيثما تزال المعارك
محتدمه هو مفتاح لبوابه شبه جزيره القرم
ونقطه هدف للهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
مطار برديانسك بقرب بحر ازوف والذي يعتبر
قاعده رئيسيه للمقاتلات الروسيه
كل منسك شماليه شبه الجزيره وديان كوي
التي تضم قاعده جويه روسيه بوابات اساسيه
للقرم بالاضافه لحمايه الطريق اي 105
الواصل بين ميليتو بول التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا وخر كيف الاوكرانيه
رعب انتشر قبل الان بين الدول الاوروبيه
الاعضاء في حلف النيتو من توسع روسيا على
حدودها الرعب بات الان من التورط في حرب
كبرى فكيف للحلف ان يواجه جيشا في طور
التحول ويخرج من معارك قاسيه لتشدد مجله
نيك على ضروره احداث تغييرات على قوات
الحلف لمواجهه خصمها في الشرق الى عمر
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل
بكين ترد الصفعه في حرب الرقائق
الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قل قائد قوات دعم السريع
في السودان محمد حمدان دقله ان قوته لن
تتراجع عن موقفها الا بانهاء ما وصفه
بانقلاب الجيش السوداني ومحاكمه كل من
اجرم في حق الشعب السوداني والعوده الى
المسار الديمقراطي حيث اتهم في رساله
صوتيه الجيشة بين قشر الفوضى وزعزعه
الاستقرار
قال نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني مالك
عقار ان اللقاء الذي جمعه برئيس جنوب
السودان سالفاكير مايردت ناقش تطورات
الوضع الراهن ومجريات الحرب والتعبئه
المستمره لها وتاثيراتها على المدنيين في
السودان والنازحين واللاجئين واوضح مالك
عقار ان الاراء اجمعت على استمرار التواصل
والتنسيق بين البلدين للدفع بعمليه فاعله
لانهاء الحرب في السودان
وفي احاطته لمجلس الامن قال المبعوث
الاممي الى السودان
فولكربرت انه لم يمر يوم منذ الخامس عشر
من ابريل دون قتال بين الجيش والدعم
السريع
لم يمر يوم بدون قتال بين الجيش والدعم
السريع منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل ونحو 900
شخص قتلوا بينهم اطفال بسبب الاشتباكات في
السودان واكثر من مليون شخص اضحو مشردين
بسبب استمرار العنف والكثير من السودانيين
حوصروا في منازلهم ويفتقرون الى الامدادات
اود ان اشير ايضا الى ان القتال ادى
لاندلاع توترات قبليه واثنيه خاصه في
دارفور طرف النزاع في السودان انتهكال
قانون الانساني الدولي
شن جهود السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اثمرت على الاتفاق جده لوقف
الاقتتال بين اطراف الصراعد السودان ومن
هنا ادعو الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع الى وقف القتال والانتقال الى
الحوار واحث الجيش والدعم السريع على ضمان
حمايه المدنيين واود الاشاره الى ان هناك
مخاطر جديه من اتساع نطاق الحرب في
السودان
[موسيقى]
ومن درفه ينضم الينا الصحفي صالح ابو
علامه ومن الخرطوم الصحه في عمار ابو شيبه
ابداء معك عمار اخر التحديثات الميدانيه
في العاصمه الخرطوم
اهلا بك راويه واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
نعم اخر تحديثات الميدانيه هنا في شرق
العاصمه قبل اللحظات من هذا المباشر
واثناء حتى المباشر نستمع كل وما زلنا
لاصوات انفجارات عنيفه هنا في منطقه بري
الشرقي العاصمه الخرطومه المحاذيه للقياده
العامه للجيش وايضا كذلك
لمطار الخرطوم ما زلنا ونستمع لهذه
الاصوات بين فتره واخرى هذه الانفجارات
العنيفه التي تتكرر وتتوالى منذ اكثر من
نصف ساعه وما زالت مستمره راويه ما يعني
دخول هذه المنطقه بعد ان كانت خارج دائره
الاشتباك او حتى القصف الجوي
والقصف الارضي المتبادل ما بين الجانبين
ولكنها عادت من جديد هذه الاصوات وهذه
الانفجارات العنيفه لا ندري حتى الان ما
نوعيه الاسلحه المستخدمه بحسب السماء بحسب
سماع الاصوات ولكن نحن نستمع للاصوات
واصوات الاشتباكات
في هذه المنطقه هي منطقه بوري الشرق
العاصمه الخرطوم يبدو ان هنالك مواجهه
مباشره باعتبار هنالك الصوت وصوت من
الجانب الاخر ما يعني
ان هنالك رد في هذه المنطقه متى ستدخل
الهدنه حيز التنفيذ عمار بعد كم ساعه
نعم هي تدخل عند الساعه التاسعه والخامسه
واربعين دقيقه اي بعد اقل من 25 دقيقه من
الان
هنالك ترقب كبير لدخول الهدنه الى حيز
التنفيذ وسريانها بشكل فعال خاصه وانه
انها سبقتها 11 هدنه لم يتم فيها الالتزام
بالشكل واضح ومباشر وتم تبادل الاتهامات
في خرقه الهدن السابقه ولكن هذه تاتي بعد
عده تطمينات وعده بنود واضحه ومؤشرات
كثيره تدل على ان اليه المراقبه ستكون
بشكل كبير وفعال ما يعني ايضا كذلك انه
يمكن من خلالها الاستفاده من عدد من
الساعات طوال زمن الهدنه وعدم اطلاق النار
وهو اطلاق نار بحسب الوصف الفعلي له جراء
الاجراءات التي تمت فيه اعلان جده انه
قصير الامد وقابل للتمديد بشكل واضح وكبير
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
يعني وما نسمعه من انفجارات هنا في منطقه
شرق العاصمه الخرطوم ان لا يمكن ان نشير
بشكل واضح لاننا دخلنا الى الدقائق
والساعات او اللحظات عن الحاسمه التي بشكل
فعلي قد تقود الى التزام بيئه وقف اطلاق
النار نستمع في هذه اللحظات ايضا الى
تحليق لطائرات الاستطلاع التابعه للجيش
السوداني وكنا نستمع الى ذوي الانفجارات
قبل لحظات من الان عمار تحدثت عن اليه
للمراقبه
وبانها ستكون فعاله هذه المره هل عرفت كيف
شكل هذه الاليه وايضا هل هنالك من ربما
يعني عقاب او اللوم او ما الى ذلك سيفرض
على الجهه التي لن تلتزم بالهدنه
نعم حسب البيانات وحسب ايضا كذلك الاشارات
الاستراتيجيه التي تم من خلالها الاشاره
الى هذه النقطه باعتبارها نقطه مفصليه في
اليه المراقبه وطالما ان هنالك اليه
مراقبه يبدو ان الفاعلين ايضا كذلك يحذرون
بشكل واضح بان هذه الهدن او هذه الهدنه
وهذه المره ستقوم مراقبه هنالك حديث عن
مراقبه بالاقمار الصناعيه وهنالك تسميه من
كلا الاطراف ثلاثه من كل طرف من الجيش ومن
الدعم السريع ومن الجانب السعودي ومن
الجانب الامريكي
للمراقبه وايضا كذلك قنوات اتصال على
الميدان من خلالها تستطيع ان توضح
ويتم من خلالها ايضا كذلك ايصال عدد كبير
من المعلومات فيما يخص
من خلق الهدنه او اذا ما تم اشتباك في
منطقه ما الجيش كان قد استبق هذه الخطوه
واعلن عن تطبيق بلاغ وهذا التطبيق من
المواطنون يمكنهم التبليغ في عدد من
الرسائل الالكترونيه عبر هذا التطبيق
للمنازل التي تم احتلالها او
العربات التي سرقت اول منهوبات الاخرى
سواء من الاسواق او ما شابه او حتى الذين
تعرضوا لضرر مباشر من جراء الاشتباكات
العسكريه مع يباح المكان ونوع الاصابه
وعدد من الاصابات الاخرى او الاضرار هذا
بحسب بيان الجيش ايضا كذلك في الجانب
الاخر قوات الدعم السريعه اشارت في بيان
انها ملتزمه التزاما تام بالهدنه وانها
سوف تدخل الى حيز التنفيذ في الوقت
المضروب
عمار اذا حدثنا من الخرطوم نتحول الى
دارفور مع صالح ابو علامه لمعرفه الوضع
هناك
هل تسمعني صالح
يبدو ان هناك تقطع في الصوت شكرا بكل
الاحوال الصحفي صالح ابو علمه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه عن تعيين
الدبلوماسي علي رضا عنايه سفيرا لطهران في
السعوديه وعمل عنايه في عده مناصب
الخارجيه كان اخرها عمله كمساعده لوزير
الخارجيه الايراني وهو الذي شارك في جميع
جولات الحوار مع السعوديه في بغداد ومسقط
وكاله تسنيم للانباء الايرانيه يشبه
الرسميه ان الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسى
تعيين علي اكبر احمد يان امينا عاما لمجلس
الامن القومي خلفا لعلي شمخاني جاء في
مرسوم صادر عن الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي
استبدال شمخان يعقبه صلته بجاسوس ايراني
مزعوم يحمل الجنسيه البريطانيه ايضا
واعدمته السلطات مؤخرا وشغل احمد يان
سابقا منصب رئيس الاركان المشتركه للحرس
الثوري وتولى رئاسه المركز الاستراتيجي
للحرس منذ عام 2006
علي اكبر احمد يان الامين العام الجديد
للمجلس الاعلى للامن القومي الايراني كان
قائدا للقوات البحريه للحرس الثوري
الايراني من عام
1997 الى عام 2000 تراس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه للحرس الثوري الايراني بين عامي
2006 تراس المركز الاستراتيجي للحرس
الثوري الايراني منذ عام 2006 ويعد عضوا
بارزا في مجمع تشخيص مصلحه النظام
[موسيقى]
لكن على عكس ما صرح اوغان فان قراره لم
يحظى بدعم تحالفه الاجداد فرئيس حزب الظفر
اومات اوزداد قال ان قرار سنان اوغان شخصي
ولا يمثل التحالف واضاف ان التحالف تخلى
عن اتخاذ القرارات الانفراديه ويعتمد
التحرك بشكل مشترك
دعا رئيس الوزراء اليوناني المنتهيه
ولايته كرياكوس ميدسوتاكس الى اقتراح جديد
في الخامس والعشرين من يونيو بعد فشل
تحقيق اي حزب الاغلبيه في الانتخابات
التشريعيه واشار الى استحاله تشكيل حكومه
جديده في ظل البرلمان الحالي وبقاء
التركيبته كما هي
[موسيقى]
اعتقد انه من واجبي ان اساهم ايضا في
التغلب على هذه العقبه في التمثيل النسبي
البسيط في اقرب وقت ممكن لذلك اعتزموا
اعاده تشكيل الائتلاف حتى نتمكن من اجراء
انتخابات جديده والتي ربما تكون في الخامس
والعشرين من يونيو
والى سباق انتخابي ساخن اخر هذه المره من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث اعلن
السيناتور الجمهوريه تمسكات نيته وخوض
السباق للفوز بترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
لانتخابات الرئاسه لكن
الاوساط الامريكيه تترقب اعلان روندسانس
حاكم فلوريدا عن ترشحه حيث يراها الكثيرون
فرس الرهان القادر على ازاحه ترامب ومن
بعده بايدن
وان لم يكن رسميا بعد لكن معركه زعامه
الحزب الجمهوري قد بدات قبل موعدها الفعلي
بخمسه اشهر
الخصماني معروفان دونالد ترامب الرئيس
السابق للولايات المتحده
ورونديسنتس حاكم فلوريدا
جمعتهما سنوات من المصالح المتبادله
ووجهات النظر في ملفات الهجره والحدود
والدعم لاوكرانيا وفرقتهما طموحات السلطه
والحكم
صعود نجم ديسانتس في اعقاب انتخابات
التجديد النصفي نوفمبر الماضي لم يكن افضل
ما حصل لدونالد ترامب فبعد ان كانت ترامب
الداعم الاول لديسانتوس كمرشح لحاكم
الولايه انقلب الاخير عليه وقرر الخروج من
عباءته
قد لا يكون الامر مستحيلا لكنه يتطلب
الشجاعه ليصبح المرء حرا كما يقول ديسنتيس
في كتابه
الاستطلاعات الاوليه تقول ان ديسانتس
يعاني امام ترامب فنحو 56% من الناخبين
الجمهوريين يؤيدون ترشحط مقابل 20% فقط
يؤيدون ترشح
الطريق لاقتناص ورقه ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري
يمر عبر ولايات التصويت المبكر وخاصه من
ولايه ايوا ديسانتس سيسعى للفوز في هذه
الولايه لاعطاء زخم لحملته في بدايتها كيف
ربما باستخدام خطابات تبرز انجازاته
السياسيه في فلوريدا او بتقويه العلاقات
الشخصيه مع مرشحين الجمهوريين اخرين بحيث
يحصل على دعمهم السياسي عند انسحابهم من
السباق
كرم حناوي العربيه
وينضم الينا من واشنطن اريك هام الخبير في
الشؤون الامريكي اهلا بك سيد اريك يعني
ترشح السيناتور تمسكات هل يمثل اي تهديد
على الاسماء الكبيره وممن قد تختصم
الاصوات
دائما احتمالات وجود مفاجات في اي
انتخابات وخاصه عندما نتحدث عن الانتخابات
ما تزال بانتظار ثمانيه اشهر قبل ظهور
النتائج فيما يتعلق بتمسكت من المثير
اهتمام ان نشير بان اعلان هذا اليوم هذا
لا يعني بانه يترشح للرئاسه لكنه يترشح
ليكون احد المؤيدين للمرشحين نعلم بانه
لديه قدرا كبيرا من الثروات الماليه وله
حضور لديه حضور في الحزب الجمهوري لكن
بناء على استطلاعات الرايات لا يمتلك
القوه التي تجعله قد يكون في صفوف القياده
بالمقارنه مع المرشحين الاخرين لكنه
لطالما صور نفسه على انه محارب يشعر
بسعدفه من المؤكد بان اي اخر سوف يعطي تمس
ت لك النظره الايجابيه في ظل عمليه
التصويت
بمن برايك سيستعين من الاسماء الكبرى
لاداره حملته الانتخابيه القادمه
اعتقد ان دي سانتوس
يعد العد الان من اجل حملته ونتوقع انه
سوف يطلق اعلنه قريبا وسوف يتطلع الى
مساعده بعض الاعضاء الاخرين من غير ولا
تزال الاسماء غير واضحه لكن
لولايه كبيره فانه لم يعمل حتى الان على
بناء العلاقات والروابط التي تجمعه مع
الحكام الجمهوريين الاخرين او سياسيين
الجمهوريين الذين سوف يمكنه الاعتماد
عليهم في مساله خوضه في في هذه السباقات
التي قد تكون صعبه ومعقده للغايه وخاصه في
في المعركه بمواجهه ترامب لدى غير الواضح
في هذه المرحله بمن سوف يستعين
ديسانتوس الذي سوف يكون
مؤيدا ومعززا له في هذه الانتخابات
المقبله
تمسكات للانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب
الجمهوري ولكنه هاجم ديسانتس توقعك لشكل
المواجهه التي ستكون بين ديسانتس وعراب
السابق دونالد ترامب
اعتقد انه يجب علينا ان ننظر الى الامور
بهذه الطريقه نعلم ان دي سانتوس ينظر اليه
بانه المنافس الاكثر حربا وتهديد الاكبر
لدون رغم ان
وفقا للبيانات التي حصلنا عليها اليوم
ينخفض باكثر من عشرين في المئه بالمقارنه
مع ترامب بالنسبه للترشيحات الحزب
الجمهوري هذا يعني ان دونالد ترامب لا
ينظر الى انه يمثل اي تهديد والبعض يحاجج
بان تمسكت قد لا يكون الا جزء من حلقه
الانتخابات التي تتعلق بدم كارتن الذي
رايناه في انتخابات عام 2016 الذي كان احد
المرشحين في الحزب الجمهوري
والذي كان يفترض ان يخدم باداره باداره رب
وهو ليس من اولئك الذين يتوقعون انهم سوف
يهاجرون ترامب حتى رغم ما تظهره بيانات
استطلاع الراي هذا ما قد يتضح بالنسبه
والسبب في ذلك فان
الرئيس السابق قد رحب باعلانه اليوم اما
دي سانتوس فهو التهديد الاكبر وليث وليس
رغم ان التمس قد يكون لديه اموال طائله
لكن الان ناخبون كثر لا يعرفون من هو هذا
الرجل تمسكوت
شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن الخبير في الشؤون
الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
استبعد مفوض شؤون الخارجه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي
مع الصين مؤكدا ان احد في الاتحاد
الاوروبي يفكر في ذلك
لا احد في الكتله الاوروبيه يتحدث عن فك
الصله الاقتصاديه مع الصين لا احد يريد
ذلك قيمه التبادلات التجاريه بيننا وصلت
الى مليارين و700 مليون يورو يوميا
المناقشات تدور حول خفض الاعتماد المتزايد
على الصين لان هذا قد يكون محفوفا
بالمخاطر لكن لا احد مستعد لفك الارتباط
بين الاقتصاد الاوروبي والصيني
هذا وضعت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج واشنطن الى مقابله بلادها
في منتصف الطريق واعاده العلاقات الى
مسارح الصحيح
نحط الجانب الامريكيه على تصحيح تصوره
للصين ووقف التدخل في شؤوننا الداخليه
وتقويد سيادتنا وامننا ومصالحنا التنمويه
والالتقاء بالصين في منتصف الطريق واتخاذ
اجراءات عمليه لاعاده العلاقات الامريكيه
الصينيه الى المسار الصحيح
وكانت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اعلنت
انها ستعمل مع حلفائها لمعالجه ما وصفته
بتشويه الصين لاسواق رقائق الذاكره بعد
اعلان الاخيره ان منتجات صنعتها شركه
مايكرون الامريكيه لصناعه رقائق الذاكرات
تشكل مخاطر جسيمه على الامن القومي وانها
ستمنع شراء منتجاتها
لكن يبدو ان الرقائق الالكترونيه امام
ازمه اخرى فالعالم بين خيارين الصحه
والتقدم التقني مع محاولات لخضر مواد
كيميائيه تدخل في صناعه هذه الرقائق
الالكترونيه نتحدث هنا عن فئه من المواد
الكيميائيه المعروفه باسم بي اف اي اس
التي تدخل في انتاج معظم الاجهزه
الالكترونيه وايضا الكهربائيه لكن تم
ربطها بعده امراض منها السرطان عده دول
حاولت حظر هذه المواد وضعت لاستخدام مواد
اخرى بالفعل عملت شركات على ايجاد بدائل
منها
اكبر شركه لتصنيع الرخائقي في العالم التي
قالت انها تحقق تقدما منذ عام 2006
تايمز البريطانيه رصدت ايضا سلبيات حظر
هذه المواد في حاله في هذه الحاله تحديدا
سيتعين على العملاء قبول ان المنتجات
الاحدث ستكلف سعرا اكبر مع غلاء المواد
الاوليه جمعيه امريكيه اشارت الى ان
القيود على مواد
بي اف اي اس يمكن ان تؤثر على صناعه تدعم
سته ملايين و200 الف وظيفه وتساهم باكثر
من تريليون دولار في الناتج المحلي
الامريكي وفي حين تعترف بعض جماعات الضغط
في صناعه الكيماويات بان الشركات ستحتاج
الى قبول حتميه فرد قيود الا ان الافضل
لها قد يكون الحصول على اعفاءات مؤقته
اخيرا قال مختصون لفاينشل تايمز ان التخلص
الكامل من مواد بي اف اي اس لن يكون ممكنا
على المدى المنظور لكن ربما يتم التخلص
منها بنسبه تتراوح بين 70 و80 في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بعد نصف دقيقه من الان
تقريبا تدخل هدنه الايام السبعه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في السودان حيز
التنفيذه وكان الطرفان قد اكد التزامهما
التام بالهدنه واعلنا انهما يريدان
احترامها بعد ترحيب الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه الدول
المعنيه
بالتنميه اذا نشاهد هذه الصور المباشره من
الخرطوم لدخول هذه الهدنه حيز التنفيذ
هي هدنه لسبعه ايام اذا بين الجيش والدعم
السريع هي ليست الهدنه الاولى تم اختراق
الهدن السابقه ولكن يبدو ونتمنى ان يكون
هناك التزام بهذه الهدنه وان تكون مختلفه
طبعا اجتمع الطرفان في مدينه جده السعوديه
وكان هناك محادثات استمرت لعده ايام
وها هي النتائج اذا هدنه الايام السبعه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع حيث دخلت حيز
التنفيذ
بعد اكثر من 16 ساعه من التحليق في الفضاء
اكتملت مناوره الالتحام للمركبه دراغون
التي تحمل راي دي الفضاء السعوديين ريان
برناوي وعلي القرني اكتملت مناوره
التحامها مع محطه الفضاء الدوليه المركبه
دراغون انطلقت بعد منتصف ليل امس من مركز
كندي الفضائي في فلوريدا بمهمه فضائيه
يشارك بها ايضا رائده فضاء اخرين هما بيلي
ويستونر من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي اول كلمه لها بعد دخول محطه الفضاء
الدوليه قالت رائده الفضاء السعوديه ريانه
برناوي من الرحله السعوديه الى الفضاء
تمثل جميع العرب
تحيه طيبه من الفضاء الخارجي الحمد لله
فضل الله وصلنا لهذه المرحله نحن الان
يعني نعيش حلم ما كنا نتخيل ان هو ممكن
يصير حقيقه الحمد لله
بدعم من الحكومه بدعم القيادتنا بدعم من
اسرنا بدعم من الجميع هذه الرحله ما
تمثلني انا لوحدي ولا تمثل بس طموحي
بالعكس يتمثل كل الوطن العربي يتمثل كل
السعوديين الحمد لله ان احنا جاتنا هذه
الفرصه ان احنا فقط نبدا نوصل الان لمحطه
الفضاء الدوليه لكن بعد كذا عندنا اكيد
طموحات اكبر واكبر
منها المريخ لازم نستكشف الفضاء هذه هي
فرصتنا زي ما تشوفوا دحين
جنسيات كثيره متجمعه في مكان واحد في
الفضاء هو اللي يجمع كل هذه الجنسيات
مختلفه بافكارهم
واستكشافاتهم ومعلوماتهم
اما رائد الفضاء السعودي على القرني فقال
في اول كلمه له بعد دخوله الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه ان التجربه التي سيعيشها تاريخيه
الحمد لله بتيسير وفضله وصلنا الى محطه
الفضاء الدوليه شكرا
لحكامنا
بقيادتهم
وحكمتهم ونظرتهم في المستقبل وتطور
البشريه شكرا لاهتمامهم بمجال الفضاء شكرا
لاسرتي على الدعم اللامحدود اللي حضيته
منهم شكرا لزوجتي واهلي جميعا شكرا لهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
بتحقيق هذا الحلم الناس وقريبا ان شاء
الله سينظمون لنا الكثير باذن الله شكرا
شكرا عكسيمكس على هذه الفرصه كانت تجربه
تجربه الاقلاع تجربه تاريخيه تجربه سوف
تخلد في ذاكرتي الى الابد
[موسيقى]
فقد عدد من المواطنين السودانيين جوازات
سفرهم التي كانت داخل سفاره الامريكيه
خلال فتره الحرب وذلك بسبب اتلافها خلال
عمليه الاجلاء وبدا الاحباط واضحا على
شباب سودانيين تحطمت امالهم بالخروج من
السودان
هكذا صار حاله يخيم على شكله الاسى
لم يتوقع الحر شرف الدين الشاب العشريني
ان ينتهي طموحه بمثل صدمه كهذه
فبعد ان سعى لتحقيق احلامه بدراسه
الماجستير في احدى الجامعات الامريكيه
بات الان يواجه احدى ماسي الحرب وصدماتها
القاسيه في السودان وقدمت
في السفاره يوم 2/4 فالدون الابوينت يوم
11/4
وفعلا مشيت الانترفيو والحمد لله كانت
الفيزا بروفت
وبعد ما رجعتها تابعت في السيستم بتاعهم
بعد يوم كانت الفيزا يشوت يعني اتطبعت في
الجواز وكان المفروض استلم الجواز مطبوع
فيه الفيزا يوم 16/4 او يوم 18/4
لم يقف عاجزا عند ذلك بل بذل كل ما في
وسعه لايجاد حل ما ثاني حاول تراسل معه من
بحريشان
اي اجراء ممكن
يطلعنا من البلد فبيجي معي عندنا لا عندنا
من البلد وفي نفس الوقت ما يعني زول تفاجئ
صراحه اتصدم انه لا يقدر يبدا دراسته في
الوقت المحدد ولا حيقدر يطلع من البلد بعد
ده ان الباسورد للاسف تدمر لم يكن وحده من
تضرر من هذا الاجراء اذ نشرت نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه مقالا مفصلا يضم اخرين
تمزقت احلام الكثيرين هنا بسبب اتلاف
السفاره الامريكيه ما بداخلها من جوازات
قبيل عمليه الاجلاء وهو بروتوكول شاركته
سفارات اوروبيه اخرى
واضعه من شملهم ذلك في قدر بروتوكول
بالنسبه للسفارات وماساه بالنسبه لاصحاب
الجوازات
المقداد حسن لقناتي العربيه والحدث انظر
مات
[موسيقى]
بحياه اكثر من مليوني شخص وتسببت بخسائر
قدرات باربع. تريليون دولار التصريح هو
للمنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه التي
اشارت ايضا الى مفارقه تسعه من كل عشر
وفيات وقعت في البلدان الناميه البلدان
التي يكاد يكون دورها هامشيا في تغير
المناخ ان قورنت بدول الصناعيه الكبرى
الى فيديو اليوم هذه المره مع خساره لم
يسببها المناخ وانما سببها حريق هائل لكن
اقصى ما فيه انه التهم تاريخا عريقا مبنى
البريد في العاصمه الفلبينيه اللي احترق
بالكامل كما نشاهد في هذه الصور لم تنجح
ثمانون مركبه اطفاء في انقاذ شيء على مدار
سبع ساعات المبنى الذي شيد قبل نحو قرن
والذي كان من اكبر مباني العاصمه احترق
بالكامل بكل ما فيه من تراث ومن بوابته
الى خامس ادواره
ولكن لنغير الجو بصوره من لندن من المكان
الذي قد تذهب اليه ويكون لديك الف سبب كي
لا تغادره حتى حين الموعد من معرض الورود
الفريد في المدينه من لندن
انتهت ملفاتنا لليوم ولكن الزميله ميسون
واخبار الساعه بانتظار تفتح ملفات جديده
مساء الخير ميسون مساء الخير راويه طبعا
الملف الاساسي هو دخول حيز دخول الهدنه في
السودان حيز التنفيذ ايضا دعم سنان اوغان
لاردوغان الموضوع الثالث هجوم على بلغراد
وايضا تحذير الصحه العالميه من وباء جديد
وهذا الخبر استرداد الله يسترنا الله
يسترنا تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات